hi everyone this is the order flows
market review for Friday May 27 2016 my
name is Michael Vos I'm the founder of
orderflows
thatcombines
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results all right
so it's Friday May 27 you know it's the
Friday before Memorial Day weekend
and actually later today you have Janet
Yellen speaking and obviously you know I
think people are are going to be you
know waiting and watching to see what
she's got to say about about any
possible raid hikes you know that said
it's been it was a very quiet morning
and it's still quiet we're still trading
around 20 2092 and a quarter uh we
opened up at at 2090 and a half you know
our range you know the range in the S&P
is is 88 up to to 94 and you know I mean
94s is just is a recent High you know
it's about 10:00 right now Chicago
time and you know say basically you're
talking about a Sixpoint range which is
ridiculous for the snps it's like I said
you know you have the holiday on Monday
and you got jenet yelling speaking this
afternoon markets you know there's not
going to there's not much to happen
today so you know I took a trade here
you know me just step it back forward
you know I bought it at 92 and a
half and yeah really I was looking see
if there's going to be a big breakout or
not and I'll tell you why why I was
looking at this 92 and A2
level I was looking at this 92 and A2
level because if you go back to
Wednesday Wednesday afternoon about 2:30
240 we hit this High here at uh 2092 A5
and we have a we don't have a ratio that
I like but you can see the volume up
here it's it's quite strong it's, 1500
you know 1100 13300 even on the bids
side it's it's 1261 the market did sell
off it sold off down to about
83 82 even the next day 83 the next day
and you when I see volume like that to
me that that's a that's an important
level you know earlier we had hit 92
even before that you know 92 again you
know we just this was Wednesday we just
sort of going up you know get up to 92
couldn't really get past it you know we
traded we got up to 932 and a half but
there was Heavy volume up there and you
know the market sold off from that going
into the close I so we got down to you
know we ended up the
day you know 80s what is that 88 and 3/4
but then you know when reopened in in
the evening that night we sold off down
to uh 2 and a half so you know even
though you know from 2:30 on Wednesday
afternoon until you know basically
midnight we sold off basically 10 points
okay we got back up on Thursday you know
we started trading the Thursday's
trading session was was extremely tight
as well
and you know after the cash open we got
up to our high at 91 and 3/4 and then we
just traded Back in Forth you can see
it's kind of a neutral day in the volume
profile is what it looks like
here and that's how we ended up today we
didn't take out the high we took out the
high though this last
night and we got up to we hit 9250 and
again you know this was at you know
after 800 PM Chicago time when we hit
that high we got a ratio bounds low
again you know got a ratio got a
Divergence yeah the market sold off okay
whoop-de-doo you know went from 92 and a
half down to 8 and a half so it was a
four-point
move and the market is very contained
you know this is Thursday night going
into Friday morning we were very very
contained you we got down to 88 wow we
made a new low down to
88 then we started coming back up we hit
92 and a half again around 7 actually it
was even before 7 I sort of remembered
it was probably around 5: in the morning
we started trading up there it would get
there and come off get there come off
you know we put in some
volume you know by the time cash opened
you know we're trading down around 90
you know this actually this bar even
though it turned this is a 10 range S&P
chart even though this bar is green you
know prior to the cash opening it look
like we're selling off um you knowly
selling off into the low it's hard to
say we're selling off when you have a a
very you know 90 2 and a half High 88
low you have a basically a four point
Range four and a half Point range but
you know as cash opened we turned around
we starting to see some buying come in
and we're getting back up here at 92 and
a half and you know I you people that
know me know me that I used to be I used
to love to buy breakouts I used to love
to cause breakouts whenever I could you
know even if it meant you know trading
it you know seeing if there's stops up
there you know we did get up towards the
other side okay you know then I figured
hey you know I only take a shot and I
was really looking for you know a quick
move up to the 94 level I did expect to
see some volume up here at you know at
three and a half you know at 3 three and
a
half but I I I really felt that if we
really going to finally break through
this 92 and a half level we can you know
finally we could make a make a move
above you know go up to 21 2100 and and
probably test our our highs you know our
contract highs you like got long and as
luck would have it we just sort of hung
around in this bar we you know we put a
lot of volume in this
bar after I got long we even traded down
to 91 and a half so you know I did take
some heat we did break out finally you
know we made a new high at 94 you know
it's hard to get excited you know when
you're a breakout Trader you're really
looking for a big breakout you're not
looking for this little high here you
know a couple points you know couple
ticks higher you know you're long at at
2 and 1/2 you know you you want to get
out at 5 you know at four four and a
half five not at you know you're not
looking for a you know three and a half
you know ideally you like to get out 94
and above you know i' like to get at
least a couple points out of it but
again we hit this level here at 94 and
we just sold off and we just came right
back down so you know this this level to
me is is an important level you can see
the volume that's trading here you know
10,000 on the offer even around it you
know you got 4,000 9,000 7,000 ,000 you
know 9,000 9,000 10,000 there's heavy
volume up here people are happy to
transact at these
levels came off okay you know I wanted
to see this point of control hold which
kind of lines up with this point of
control from earlier you see you got
these two points of controls I want to
see this area you know I want to see I
still want to see buying come in you
know there's a lot of buying here at
these levels
so you know I'm not giving up just yet I
know that it's a very tight range as
well so I I was going to be very
surprised if this trade was going to
really get away from me pretty quick you
know we're in a four-point Range all
night I can't expect all of a sudden
we're going to move you know Five Points
right off this high so for me it didn't
feel much downside risk you know when
you sort of take everything into account
you know I've got some support levels
down here which we tested it held and it
bounced right back up got back up to
9350 then again you know right now I
right now it's it's a little bit after
10 and we're trading around this area
here around 93 well now it's at 2 and A2
but we were trading you know three 3 and
a/4 3 and 1/2 you know 3 and a qu 3es
you know 275 back and forth here
honestly you know I originally I thought
I I threw an offer in there at three and
a half tried to get a point
out and it was just really going nowhere
I I just I honestly I came in today not
expecting to trade at
all and this trade you know it's sort of
set up I mean it it's I hate to say it
was an orderflow trade it's honestly
it's not you know it's a level trade I
was watching this level for a few days
and I wanted to see as we're getting
through it and we kept testing it kept
testing it you know now that the cash
just opened if you remember the last
couple days every time after the cash
opened we would make a new high and just
go higher well except for yesterday but
I sort of looking anticipating the same
sort of thing and you know we did break
out break out a little bit more and just
came right back off start going
sideways you know again you know when
it's trading at 2 and a half I'm not
looking to scratch it because you know I
I know we're just trading around this
area in here that it's probably going to
give me a chance to get out you know I
would have been perfectly happy to take
a small loss on this trade you know even
down to one and a half to get out but I
know that this Market is just going to
rotate around you know 2 and a half to
three you know even down to two so you
know there's going to be chances for me
to get out I I do expect us now just to
go sideways
ahead of Janet Yellen speaking you know
the fact that we couldn't build on this
move initially right after the cash open
know this is 9:00 Chicago time and you
know the fact that we didn't really
react and sell off you know we made a
high but we didn't sell off you know we
did come down to
91 you know but we just snapped right
back and there was a pretty quick snap
back so you know I do expect us to go go
sideways now so you know I said I got
out at 3 and a qu so you know it's not
the greatest trade you know it's not
something I'm going to beat on my chest
and say you know send out videos hey you
know I made whatever on you know on a
quick trade no you know I felt that this
was a pretty lowrisk setup in terms of
Market
structure you know I didn't feel there
was much downside you know the market
could have come off I think but I've got
some support levels here at you know 91
a half 91 and 3/4 orders I said we did
test it we got down to 91 but then this
Market snapped right back you know I
said if and we have the opening price
here so you know on slow days where days
where Market is going nowhere you know
watch the opening price because the
market will basically gyate around it
you know go you know hold as support
then it'll become resistance back and
forth you back and forth but you know I
said I had an opportunity to get out in
here I didn't really expect it to come
back up I mean there's not much really
in the order flow I mean there was one
ratio here but really this level here at
2 and a half I I thought if we can get
through it and we did get through it
okay I mean I didn't get long when we're
back up poking here I got long after we
traded up up to here to three and three
and a quarter and then came back down
you know that's when I said hey you know
I I think I could probably get a little
bit I get something out of this trade
you know my whole thing is order trading
with order flow and then honestly this
this is not necessarily an
orderflow trade in the sense that you
know there's no ratios or anything like
that this was something more you know is
a level that I've been watching from the
order flow from Wednesday when we hit
this High here you know there wasn't a
ratio but it was very close you know
it's 71 I I like 69 and
Below but you know in the order flow on
Wednesday there was some nice decent fat
volume up there at that high and the
market did react and then I just noticed
I mean yesterday we didn't get quite get
up there we got within 3/4 of a point
and then you know overnight or you know
Thursday evening trade date Friday we
did hit that level again two and a half
and there was still that volume I did
expect when we finally get back up there
to be that volume and then we hit it
again you know at 5: in the
morning came
off then cash opened okay and cash
opened and now we're seeing a run back
up to it so you know now you got
real volume coming into the
market and we hit that level got through
it yeah you didn't get like a bunch of
stops triggered and and immediately
Spike up three points but you know we
hit it came off
okay at least now it's been violated I'm
looking for you know another push up
again again you know
if you know for this trade for me to
fail you know it'd have to come down you
know at least test get on the other side
of this opening price at at 902 even you
know come down to
892 you know this was basically my stop
level here you worst case
scenario but you know as you know it did
get down in this bar on me down to
around I think 91 before you know turned
back
up but then you know it never really
followed through and then it sort of
went sideways on me so you know I took
my chance you know Market gives you I
think Market gives you opportunities to
get out with this small scratch or a
small winner I say a small scratch a
scratch or small winner or small
loser when a trade is not working out
and you know I took that opportunity to
get out here what I do think is
interesting now is we're up here still
at the
high and you got a lot of negative
Deltas going on here even though this
bar has got a very strong positive Delta
and the fact that we haven't been able
to build off this strong positive Delta
is not necessarily the greatest sign yet
you know we'll see I think I think the
Market's kind of in a holding pattern
waiting for Janet Yellen to speak and
and then everyone will take off for a
nice long
weekend okay so thank you for watching
this video you know if you can subscribe
to my YouTube channel so I know that you
guys are watching my videos and you know
and appreciate them and you know to
learn more about trading with orderflow
and the software that I use in this
video be sure to visit my website www.
orderflows
and you know hey if if you think it's
too expensive you know email me this's
my email here Mike overflow.com and you
know we'll work something out you know I
said it's it's about educating you to
trade with orderflow don't say have to
use my software you know ideally yeah
because all my videos and all my
education is built around my software I
had my software
developed because the existing orderflow
software out there
didn't analyze the market with orderflow
yeah it just gave you a footprint chart
well you get a footprint print chart
from anywhere but you have to know what
you're looking at and you know people
that I was teach that I was teaching
they don't know where to start so that's
why I sort of created the software with
the indicators that I say indicators but
you know with the things that I look for
in the market that I said they're not
necessarily indicators they're more
things to sort of slap you upside this
head the head and say hey idiot don't
miss this this is happening right now in
the market and you know it's up to you
whether you want to take it or not you
know orderflow itself is not a trading
system it's a method of trading the
market it's an approach to the market
it's it's not a a black box it's not you
know a a go no go go no go setup you
know you know you buy when you see green
or you sell when you see red no it's not
like that you have to it teaches you how
to read the market and how to understand
the market you know which as Traders
that's what you have to do you know it's
not about f in the latest greatest
indicator you know like I said you know
W blue means buy red means sell no it's
not about that you should really
understand the market so anyway you know
send me an email if you want to discuss
uh
orderflow uh I'll get back to you when I
can you know sometimes it may take me a
day or so but you I'll do my best to get
back to you so thanks for watching this
video have a good weekend bye-bye